good morning John I don't know whether
I'm capable of making a decision like on
the scale of things I'm a very good
decision maker I could crack him out
like no problem what I mean is that I
don't know if I or anyone is capable of
doing anything that wasn't predetermined
from the moment of the Big Bang I've
seen some fairly compelling arguments
that like the initial starting state
conditions for the universe define the
words that are coming out of my mouth
right now
pant suit golden tug boat larger Park
larger Park that had to have come from
nowhere right no it came from the Big
Bang at least that's what a lot of smart
people say no matter what I do right now
I am NOT making a decision like just get
down to the beach job stroll it put the
seagull hey Bo get my head nod [ __ ] OC
goes stop it now over there before I did
that doesn't seem possible that like not
only me singing that song but also the
lyrics to the weird seagulls Yoda's song
and all the way to Emily Dickinson and
William Shakespeare all that stuff was
just the inevitable consequence of
particles knocking against each other in
seeking lower energy states and if there
is randomness if it is in fact
impossible to predict everything that
will ever happen based on the starting
conditions of the Big Bang then it's not
like human decisions that are
introducing that randomness it's weird
quantum fluctuations
it's particles doing particle things me
the story that I tell myself about
myself it's just another inevitable
physical phenomena I'm just a ball
rolling down a hill and I've come to a
place where it kind of rationally accept
this in philosophy this is called
determinism that everything that happens
is part of an inevitable chain of cause
and effect but in my everyday life
of course I ignore this I choose with
the free will that I don't have to
ignore the fact that I don't have free
will because I know wait for it that if
I accepted the fact that it didn't have
free will I would make a bunch of
different decisions that would
negatively impact my ability to joyfully
flourish on this space ball side note
I'm calling planets space balls now and
if you don't like that there's nothing I
can
about it need calling planet space balls
is just an inevitable consequence of the
starting conditions of the universe
sorry anyway where was I accepting that
I am not actually making decisions does
not fit with my lived experience like I
can say free will doesn't exist and then
I still have to like decide what to make
my video about I have to decide what to
have for dinner I have to decide what
the next word is that's gonna come out
of my mouth and so and this is the
actual point of the video
I live in intentional ignorant of a
reality I also kind of do this
really inevitable situation in which
there will be one human being left and
then that last human will die I'm a
science dude I believe in the intrinsic
goodness of having a more accurate
understanding of the world today than
you did yesterday both as individuals
and as a collective species and yet
there is a very short list of things I
think it's just better to ignore because
my ultimate goal isn't to have like the
perfect understanding of the universe my
ultimate goal is to find happiness and
to help other people do that too I don't
know that this video has served that
purpose but I tried John I'll see you on
Tuesday if you're feeling a little rough
after that one I apologize that's not my
goal this always helps my toddler I'm a
little boy hopefully that's that's
better now